vingt-cinq ans de carrière et 70
millions de jeux vendus
sonic le hérisson de sega n'a pas pris
une ride anna derrière les amateurs de
vieilles consoles ont pu se replonger
dans les jeux vidéo ancienne génération
un rendez vous pour les plus jeunes mais
aussi les plus grands les papas les
mamans qui ont joué aux consoles quand
ils étaient petits qui peuvent jouer
avec leurs enfants et faire découvrir
des consoles local il auquel il jouait à
eux quand il était petit et on sort ce
qui est très drôle c'est de voir que les
enfants tout de suite là bas ils
s'adaptent tout de suite à la console
quoi c'est intuitif chez eux c'est là
c'est très drôle de les voir jouer
gamecube megadrive super nintendo des
consoles devenu culte des personnages
emblématiques une passion pour les vieux
jeux qui a un nom le retrogaming patrick
est un habitué de cette pratique
il a installé trois écrans pour
s'adonner à son passe-temps portables ou
de salon une dizaine de consoles
différentes occupent son appartement
la plus vieille que j'ai je pense ça va
être la playstation donc est sorti en
europe en 1995 je crois là c'est tomb
raider le premier sur la première
playstation c'est le plaisir de rejouer
à des des jeux auxquels j'avais pu jouer
à l'époque quand j'étais ado ensuite il
ya aussi le fait de pouvoir les
redécouvrir avec soin une meilleure
qualité d'image soit sur des écrans
différents
sa collection a pris forme au fil des
années grâce aux dons de ses amis le
retro gaming une forme de nostalgie qui
peut atteindre des sommes
impressionnantes
certains jeux sont vendus plus de 1000
euros même avec le succès des nouvelles
versions la première lara croft a encore
de beaux jours devant elle
elle fête cette année ses 20 ans